i have some interesting clips for you of
fox news host chris wallace
calling out republican senator tom
cotton for the obvious
brazen bold-faced stunning hypocrisy by
republicans
on the replacement of ruth bader
ginsburg to the supreme court
these clips i'm going to play for you
are not notable because we're shocked
that republicans are being hypocrites
the clips are notable because of how
casually and comfortably
republicans like tom cotton use obvious
bad arguments for why they couldn't fill
antonin scalia's seat back in 2016
but now they should fill ruth bader
ginsburg's seat with only 45 days
remaining before the election now as a
reminder
when antonin scalia passed away during
barack obama's presidency
republicans control the senate as they
do now and they blocked
the replacement of antonin scalia with
merrick garland who was barack obama's
choice that was with nine months before
the election
now we have just 44 days before the
election and republicans are saying now
it makes perfect sense for donald trump
to replace ruth bader ginsburg so let's
get into it here is chris wallace
using tom cotton's own words against him
or at least trying to
back in 2016 after justice scalia died
president obama
named federal judge merrick garland uh
as his new nominee to the court and as
you well know
you were part of the senate then senate
republicans blocked the choice
of garland here's what you said at that
time
in a few short months we will have a new
president and new senators
who can consider the next justice with
the full faith
of the american people why would we cut
off the national debate
about this next justice why would we
squelch the voice of the people
why would we deny the voters a chance to
weigh in on the makeup of the supreme
court
now garland was nominated nine months
before the election and you were saying
then
nine months before the election it was
wrong to deny
voters a chance to weigh in so if it was
wrong then
nine months before the election why is
it okay now
six weeks before the election
so chris in 2014 the american people
elected republic a republican majority
of the senate to put the brakes
on president obama's judicial
nominations in 2018 we had a referendum
on this question just a month before the
2018 midterms
we had the vote on justice kavanaugh
there could not have been a clear
mandate because the american people
didn't just re-elect republicans they
expanded our majority
they defeated four democratic senators
who voted against justice kavanaugh they
reelected the one democratic senator
who did vote for justice kavanaugh so we
have a clear
mandate to perform our constitutional
duty that's what the senate majority
will do now
that's what we did back in 2016 as well
this is one of the biggest logic
pretzels that i've ever seen from
republicans it actually
boggles the mind if you're not sure what
tom cotton is talking about
that's exactly the point it's meant to
be confusing let's think it through
tom cotton says there's no hypocrisy
here
because right after kavanaugh's
confirmation
there was a midterm election in 2018 and
republicans gained seats showing that
the public had no problem
with the confident confirmation of brett
kavanaugh this is
a complete non-sequitur it it has
nothing to do with the issue at hand
first of all the senate only has one
third of the seats up for re-election
every election cycle one-third of the
senate
is up for re-election in any given
election year
in 2018 the senate seats up for
re-election
favored republicans it had nothing to do
with some kind of american referendum
on whether or not it was okay to
fill brett kavanaugh see i mean it has
it has nothing to do with it it is a
complete and total red herring
secondly this is about presidents not
senates
they said obama can't pick someone
during his last
year and now they're saying trump can
pick someone during what are the last 44
days before the election
it is incoherent and chris wallace calls
him out
you really don't think there is any
hypocrisy at all
in saying we need to give voters because
i mean you can parse the 2014 election
the 2018 election any way you want
but you stated a pretty firm principle
in 2016 about merrick garland
it's wrong to deny voters a chance to
weigh in you don't see any hypocrisy
between that position then in this
position now
chris the senate majority is performing
our constitutional duty and fulfilling
the mandate that the voter
voters gave us in 2016 and especially
in 2018 i i just
when i i promise this is the last
question on this particular subject
let's do a thought experiment you're a
lawyer the you you do hypotheticals or
you did when you were in law school
let's assume if president trump were to
lose
in the election six weeks from now if
the senate were to change hands so that
it went from republicans to democrats in
a lame duck session
with a president who'd been defeated and
a republican majority that was about to
be
out of office some would say the lamest
of lame duck sessions are you saying you
still think it would be proper
to vote to confirm president trump's
nominee to the court
chris as i said we're going to move
forward without delay and there will be
a vote on this nominee
these are just bad people that's
it chris wallace exposes the hypocrisy
he does
i don't know that it matters to the fox
news audience donald trump has coined
this new uh refrain at his rallies
fill that seat and they are moving
forward
and unfortunately it looks like they're
going to have the numbers to do it
so we can't control everything but
we can control voting in november
and we all need to get out and vote
to end this insanity they may get this
seat filled they may not ultimately
you know we can only do so much and we
should do whatever we can do
but they need to be punished tom cotton
needs to be punished
lindsey graham needs to be punished he's
got an opponent jamie harrison
these people need to be held accountable
for their hypocrisy
for their brazen double standards and
chris wallace is trying but they just
don't care
at the end of the day they do not care
that they are obvious hypocrites
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at d pakman remember you can get the
daily audio podcast
anywhere you want itunes stitcher
spotify pandora don't miss it
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor
i've tried tons of different face masks
this year like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over 150 dollars you
can get there by going
to davidpakman.com mask the link is
under this video
and you can save 20 on everything in
their store when you use the coupon code
david